-Thank you so much
for coming on.
-I could not be happier.
I'm so excited to be here.
-We're so happy that
you're here.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on the film
"Purple Hearts."
You worked so hard on this film.
It comes out on Netflix.
And not just comes out.
It's the number-1 film,
globally, out of all Netflix.
I mean, it's the
biggest movie out there.
And you're all -- It's all you.
Your fingerprints are
all over this.
You're in the soundtrack.
You star in it.
You're funny.
You're awesome in it.
It's the biggest thing.
How do you feel?
-I was talking to my mom the
other night about all of this
and I realized that I can't find
a word to describe how I feel.
I'm just so overjoyed
and overwhelmed and grateful.
And, you know, I poured my heart
and soul into this film,
and for it to be
loved by the world
as deeply as I loved making it
is just incredible.
-Good for you.
-Thank you.
How did --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Explain to me, how does the
movie -- how did it come about?
-So, about five years ago, I was
shooting a show in Portland
called "Pretty Little Liars:
The perfectionists."
And my incredible director,
Liz Allen --
she approached me around
Christmastime with a script
and she said,
"Merry early Christmas."
And it said "'Purple Hearts.'"
And it was a rough draft
of this movie.
And she said that she wanted to
embark on this journey
as more than just
actor and director,
but as partners and producers.
And that's how
the journey began.
And five years later,
after shooting the film,
writing the soundtrack,
producing it, here we are.
And it's just been
the most incredible journey.
-But, I mean, kind of
perfect for you
because you're a great singer
and a great actor.
-Do you actually
want to know how she
wanted to work with me again?
-Yeah.
-I was in the middle of
the woods in Portland,
shooting a dramatic scene.
And before I did my
dramatic scenes at the time,
I had to sing a song.
And "Star is Born"
had just come out.
And I was belting -- and I
thought no one could hear me --
the ending song,
"I'll Never Love Again."
And she was like --
She overheard this crazy girl
in the middle of the woods
belting "I'll Never Love Again"
and she's like,
"I have to work with her."
-"I have to find who this is."
-She's like, "Who is this girl!"
-"Oh, my gosh.
What are you doing?"
And she goes -- Yeah.
-I'm so grateful
for that moment.
-Thank you, Gaga.
Yeah, there you go.
-Thank you.
-Have you always wanted to
sing and act since you remember?
-I don't remember
ever not wanting to do this.
It's so much more
than what I do.
It's who I am.
-And a very supportive mom, too.
I got to meet
your beautiful mom backstage.
-She's my everything.
She's here
in the audience tonight.
So, thank you, Mom.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good job, Mom.
For anyone who hasn't seen
"Purple Hearts" yet,
can you set it up for everyone?
-Yeah, so, "Purple Hearts,"
to me, is a love story,
but it's so much more than
a love story.
It's a story about two people,
two hearts from opposite worlds,
one red, one blue, who were
raised to hate each other,
who, through the power of love,
they come together
and form a beautiful shade
of purple.
And if love can do this
with two hearts,
it's what the world
needs now more than ever.
-Yeah, that is exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Sofia Carson in
"Purple Hearts."
Take a look at this.
-Alright, I, uh -- I get this.
-What do you get?
-You.
Yeah.
-Me?
-Yeah, yeah.
You're kind of predictable.
I've -- I've
met your type before.
Yeah.
-Oh, do tell.
-Drive a Lexus
that your parents paid for,
but it's a hybrid, so it's okay.
You probably tweet a lot
about other people's rights,
but when it actually
comes down --
- Sorry.
It's just fascinating to me.
Do you -- do you have a PhD
in mansplaining?
-When it actually comes down to
fighting for these rights,
you don't want to
do anything, right?
Because guns are mean,
and you're a pacifist.
I guess it's our job to go off
and fight those battles
for you, right?
I bet you have
a little "Peace/love" tattoo
on your back to prove it.
-On my ass, actually,
which you can't touch,
but you can kiss.
-Oh, snap! Come on!
The movie is a huge hit,
and so is the soundtrack,
which you co-wrote.
-Yes, with Justin Tranter.
Thank you so much.
-Congrats on that.
Come on, you're doing it all.
I just -- Not to put you on
the spot or anything,
but, you know, we always
have the silver mic here.
And we have the greatest band of
all late night, The Roots.
Could you do a little bit of
your hit "Come Back Home"?
-Are you asking me to sing
"Come Back Home"
with The Roots right now?
-Yes.
-I would be honored.
But can you sing it with me?
-Want me to?
-Will you guys sing just
the very end of the song?
I'll say...
♪ Come back home ♪
-Yeah, we can do that.
-♪ Come back home ♪
-There you go.
-Yeah. We got this.
-Okay, guys, you ready?
♪♪
♪ We're drowning in our eyes ♪
♪ Don't know what we'll find ♪
♪ I'm not sure,
should we fly or fight this? ♪
♪ We're terrified ♪
♪ Pretending now
that we don't care ♪
♪ Tension cuts, cuts the air ♪
♪ We're more than scared ♪
♪ I'm drowning in your eyes ♪
♪ I'm terrified ♪
♪ Letting my fears show
till I can face 'em ♪
♪ Letting my tears go
till I can taste them ♪
♪ How do I know
where you and I go? ♪
♪ Damn it, I hope you ♪
♪ Come back home ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Come back home ♪
Sofia Carson, everybody.
"Purple Hearts"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Lauren Spencer-Smith
performs after the break.
Stick around, everybody.